so you remember jack phillips i've
talked about him on the show plenty of
times i think he's one of the great
heroes of religious liberty in modern
times and i don't think that's an
exaggeration well the vengeful spiteful
bullies of the LGBT lobby will not leave
this guy alone they just they just can't
and so the owner of the masterpiece cake
shop you know he had the audacity to
beat them in the supreme court after he
refused to make a cake for a gay wedding
well he refused to to customize a cake
for a gay wedding several years ago
ends up in the Supreme Court as you know
and and he won there and that victory
has not gone unpunished so now it's it's
important as we follow this saga we
follow the next chapter in the saga of
of Jack Phillips verse the LGBT bullies
it's important to really pay attention
because this gives you it shows you how
the LGBT lobby operates it gives you a
very clear look at their methods and
it's a it is a it's a pretty disturbing
picture so backing up for a moment Jack
Phillips is back in court this week this
time for declining to bake a cake
celebrating a man's gender transition
his so-called gender transition quote
unquote and a federal judge said this
week that he is inclined to let the the
case absurd as it is go forward which
perhaps will lead eventually to
masterpiece cake shop the sequel
debuting at the Supreme Court within it
within a couple of years maybe now if
you recall the Supreme Court they
smacked down the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission for its despicable treatment
of Phillips last time around but it
doesn't seem that the Colorado Civil
Rights Commission has learned it's
lesson or taken the lesson to heart
because here we are again so here's the
background on this case in in June of
2017 on the same day that the Supreme
Court announced that it will be taking
Phillips's case his previous case a
lawyer named
autumns Gardena called masterpiece
asking for a cake to celebrate the
anniversary of his
so called transition into a woman okay
now Phillips of course politely declined
scar Dena immediately contacted the
Civil Rights Commission and the petty
despots of the Commission quickly
decreed that he had committed a a human
rights violation my understanding of the
case is that the the man who called he
wanted a blue cake with you know a cake
with blue icing and that's pink inside
he wanted a blue exterior pink interior
to celebrate his gender transition from
what from what I've read he didn't ask
for any words on the cake so he didn't
ask for the cake to say happy gender
transition day or whatever so that that
of course raises a question of how would
Jack Phillips have known that the cake
was for a gender transition if you just
call asking for a cake that's blue
outside pink inside it's not like Jack
Phillips is going to say now wait a
second is this to celebrate a gender
transition no you could have just asked
for the stupid cake and not said what
it's for it wouldn't have been a problem
so how did you how did Jack Phillips
know well it must be because scar Dena
volunteered that information for no
reason or there was a reason what's the
reason well obviously the entire thing
was nothing but an utterly transparent
setup scar Dena who had previously
harassed masterpiece cake shop with
requests for cakes with satanic imagery
he wanted cakes with sex toys this time
he called on that particular day this is
a lawyer remember so he's aware of
Supreme Court cases on that particular
day he calls and and he calls obviously
for the express purpose of being denied
he wants to be denied the cake there
clearly is no other reason to tell a
baker that the pink and blue cake is
meant to celebrate a gender transition
there's no reason to do that
and and of course a cake to celebrate a
gender transition which happened by the
way years ago is a bizarre in arbitrary
occasion for a cake anyway but if for
some reason a person really did want a
cake for that purpose
and genuinely felt the need to announce
it to the person behind the counter at
the bakery there's no legitimate or
honest reason to choose the one bakery
in the whole country that's famous for
having qualms about these kinds of
things so scarred inna the lawyer is is
a bully and a harasser and nothing more
no rational person believes that his
request was made in good faith and even
if it was which I emphasize again it was
not but even if it was a business owner
has the right to decline to lend his
labor and his skill to a celebration of
genital mutilation um now Philips his
lawyers Jack fellers
they've argued that that his belief in
the biological nature of sex is a
religious conviction and it may well be
and perhaps that's the best legal
framing so that's why they're putting it
that way but it's also a rational
scientific intellectual conviction as
well you don't need to be religious to
believe that a man is a man and womans a
woman so I you know a man should be no
more force to violate his reason than he
should be forced to violate his religion
the Colorado Civil Rights Commission
wants him to violate both and they're
they're going along with an obvious
setup concocted by a guy who had
previously asked previously asked for a
cake featuring an actual working model
of a dildo his words they're going along
with that guy in order to make their
point so this is straightforward
persecution this is a government agency
seeking to destroy a private citizen for
his personal beliefs and nothing more
and the bureaucrats behind this campaign
have obviously now officially forfeited
the claim that they're really seeking
equality or tolerance or whatever
because they know like we all do that
Phillips is being railroaded here and
and there aren't even any hurt feelings
for them to worry about not that hurt
feelings matter buts cárdenas feelings
weren't even hurt with the other case
maybe the
men who were turned down no I think that
was a setup also but if it wasn't then
maybe their feelings were legitimately
hurt that doesn't matter who cares
that's not that's that's not important
you're allowed to hurt people's feelings
in America but in this case you only you
don't even have that to hang your hat on
this guy got exactly what he wanted
which was to not get what he asked for
he's a conniving scheming fraud and so
are the despots in the commission
no matter your ideological leanings you
should be absolutely opposed to this you
should be outraged by it this is this is
just this is a government agency
persecuting a private citizen you should
be against that even if you hate
everything that Jack Phillips stands for
and I feel the need to clarify once
again something that you know I've made
this point many times and I doubt that
this next reiteration will make any
difference whatsoever but I'm gonna say
it anyway this case and all of these
kinds of cases have nothing to do with
business owners discriminating against
certain classes of people or certain
demographics of people in other words
just because you support Phillips his
right to decline to make a certain kind
of cake doesn't mean you would or must
or should support his right to decline
to serve a certain race or ethnicity
okay there is a huge difference between
Phillips and a racist business owner who
decided who declines or deny service to
black people so that comparison makes no
sense it doesn't hold up it's not the
same thing there's a huge difference
between the two things it's not at all
the same in one case the business owner
is just saying we don't want to lend our
services or our product to this
particular event we don't want to
promote this particular idea or belief
but we're happy to serve you as a person
in in the other hand on the other hand
the business owner is saying we don't
want to serve you as a person doesn't
matter what the product is doesn't
matter what the event is it's you as a
person as a black person or whatever
that we are refusing to serve those are
two completely different things
if Jack Phillips had said your again you
you know you're a gay couple you're not
welcome in this establishment that would
be one thing but that's not what he said
in fact he said you can buy whatever you
want here you're welcome to buy whatever
you want
I just can't customize a cake
specifically for a gay wedding I'll
customize a cake for your birthday for
for your for Halloween for whatever you
want or in fact well actually he doesn't
do Halloween cakes because he does which
is which is another good point that Jack
Phillips is is a particular kind of
Christian that is opposed to Halloween
so he doesn't make Halloween cakes
that's an event is he discriminating
against people who celebrate Halloween
no he just
that's just he doesn't believe in I
believe in Halloween I believe in Holly
I'm fine with Halloween I don't have any
problem with with Halloween so if I went
to Jack Phillips and I said can you make
a cake for Halloween and he said no I
wouldn't I wouldn't say I'm being
discriminated against I would say well
this is a guy that just has a problem
with this particular event fine I'll go
so I'll go to one of the other 50,000
different bakeries or stores where I can
go to get this kind of cake so there's a
difference between that and refusing to
serve a certain kind of person now as it
happens I do believe that business
owners have the right or should have the
right to deny service to anyone for any
reason
so yes if it were up to me I would let a
racist business owner does deny service
to black people I would let a business
owner hang a sign in the window saying
we don't serve black people here black
people not welcome I would allow that if
it were up to me it's his business
it's his labor it's his property it's
his it's not society's it's not the
customers it's not the collectives it's
not the countries it's not the
government's it's his and if he wants to
destroy his business overnight by
hanging a no blacks allowed sign in the
window so be it he'll be bankrupt within
12 hours that's his loss I mean if
you're against racism you should be fine
with that you should say yeah all the
racist business owners go ahead
advertise your racism and then we'll and
then you'll be finished you're not gonna
have a business any more more that the
market will punish you now it may be 50
60 years ago it would have been
different in a lot of places in the
country
so maybe that's a different case but
these days there is just nowhere in the
country where you could get away with
being an openly racist business owner
denying service to everyone except white
people you couldn't possibly get away
with that without going going out of
business immediately and so fine the
market will take care of it the market
will punish you as well it should
besides if you're patronizing an
establishment that's run by someone who
hates your guts because of your race
wouldn't you like to know it so you can
patronize somewhere else so that's
that's the way that should work in my
opinion but that has nothing again to do
with the masterpiece cake they are
completely different it is perfectly
possible and perfectly reasonable
perfectly consistent to take a less
libertarian view than I do on the
general issue of businesses denying
services to people while at the same
time supporting Phillips so you could
take the position that no it should be
it should not be allowed you should not
be allowed to deny service to people
based on race or ethnicity or whatever
yet I still think that Phillips had the
right to do what he did that's a
perfectly consistent position as well
because they're not the same thing all
right now I turn to a story that hasn't
got as much attention as some of the
other events of the week this is from
The Daily wire it says the Trump
administration announced on Thursday
that it would move to make sure
able-bodied Americans work to receive
food stamp benefits which the US
Department of Agriculture said it could
save billions of dollars in taxpayer
money each year the agriculture
department unveiled expanded work
requirements in the Supplemental
Nutrition Assistance Program snap
according to the proposed rule those who
are able-bodied adults without
dependents would need to work at least
20 hours per week up to age 59 in order
to receive government assistance and the
Agriculture Department said that this is
meant to make it so that this is an
assistance a system of assistance not a
way of life not
reading a lifelong dependency and so on
and this is exactly the right approach I
think that President Trump should be
commended here it's fair it's
compassionate to encourage people to
work is compassionate now some people
think somehow it's cruel to expect
people to work you expect them to
contribute but the opposite is really
the case it isn't good for a person to
be dependent it is it's bad for the soul
that's bad for your well-being as a
human being
work is good for the soul a person needs
to feel like they're chipping in and
they're taking part and they're
contributing so like they're doing
something in life so this is not only
fair to the taxpayers who are funding
this system but I think it's also the
fairest and most compassionate thing for
the individuals involved so I just
wanted to mention that I think it's a
good thing what else
okay very briefly according to some
recent polling Joe Biden is the Democrat
frontrunner for the nomination in 2020
now Joe Biden if he won he would be 78
when he's sworn in 78 years old that
would make him 82 at the end of his term
and if he won again
he'd be 86 upon leaving office if he
survives that long which is no guarantee
because the life expectancy for men I
think is is 84 years old
I mean 78 is just crazy
okay 78 would be old for a pope when
your Pope old that then you're super old
president old is like late 60s early 70s
Pope old is when you're pushing 80 late
60s for a Pope is yeah that's Pope Young
80 is Pope old so I you know I really
think that there there are many reasons
to to be opposed to the idea of Joe
Biden being president but before you get
to any of that he's just too old 78 is
too at a certain point nobody is
immortal okay at a certain point your
body and your mind start to slow down
and and
happens to everyone in their 70s
certainly by your late 70s now I know
you might say oh my grandmother is 87
years old and she's still sharp as a
tack yeah I don't de now deny that she
is but she certainly she is she has
certainly slowed down from from what she
used to be everyone does it happens to
everyone unless you die before that so
if there's not a knock on older people
it's just the reality of the situation
the idea that we have a 78 year old man
doing the most stressful job in in the
in the country is just absurd think
about how much the presidency aged as a
person look at look at like a picture of
George Bush in 2000 verse George Bush in
2008 or Obama in 2008 verse Obama in
2016 it just ages you it's like when
you're in the presidency it's like
you're on dog years you know every year
is seven years so the wear and tear and
everything it's just it's ridiculous me
if we have a if we have an age minimum
for the presidency of 35 then should
there be an age maximum wouldn't it make
sense to say that you know going forward
you can't be older any older than 70
when when you first enter office now if
you enter office at 70 you know then
you're in and so if maybe then if you we
could we could think of what the rule
will be but maybe for your first run or
for your first term you can't be any
older than 70 if you win a term then you
can run for will re-election but I
really think it's time to consider
something like that I mean the Democrats
are looking at having Bernie Sanders I
think would be around 78 as well so
they're looking at having just between
the two of them that's that's over a
hundred and fifty they'd be over 150
years old between the two of them
it's just crazy my opinion all right
last thing as we get ready for Christmas
this will be my last show until until
the new year so I thought before we end
things for Christmas I just wanted to
and this is a
a discussion every year around this time
we start talking about what are the
worst and what are the best Christmas
songs now as far as the best Christmas
songs I think I think there are dozens
of really good Christmas songs it's hard
for me to choose between them o come o
come Emmanuel is technically an Advent
song but if I can count that that's my
personal favorite there are many great
silent night is a is a joy as it is a
great cause Joey to the worlds it gets a
great Christmas song but as far as the
worst Christmas songs I want to go down
here here's my top ten list of the worst
Christmas songs number one being the
absolute worst okay let's just go
through these very briefly these are the
songs that should be banished abolished
legally you should be legally prevented
from playing them from listening to them
from performing them in my opinion so
number ten wonderful Christmas time Paul
McCartney number nine Christmas shoes is
an absolutely terrible song momentum of
this song is just this is a song it's
about a guy who's at I mean you've heard
it but the guys in line that the day
before Christmas at a store and there's
a kid in front of them buying shoes for
his mother who's dying of cancer it's
just a it's just so emotionally
manipulative and SAP you never it's a
terrible song so number ten wonderful
Christmas time number nine Christmas
shoes number eight wonderful Christmas
time number seven do they know it's
Christmas
number six wonderful Christmas time
number five Feliz Navidad
number four wonderful Christmas time
number three all I want for Christmas is
you
number two wonderful Christmas time and
number one the absolute worst Christmas
song in existence is you guessed it
wonderful Christmas time that is
wonderful Christmas time is not only the
worst Christmas song by a mile but it is
arguably the worst song that has been
recorded in at least the last 200 years
probably in human history
and the thing is I think we all agree on
that don't have you ever met anyone who
likes that song know we all hate that
song and yet it appears on the radio you
hear it at the department stores if for
some reason you go to a department store
rather than just buying everything
online it just we can't escape it even
though everybody hates it so maybe it's
time that we all just move on from that
song which we all hate and then we can
truly actually have a wonderful
Christmas time all right so I hope you
guys all have a blessed Christmas and
I'll talk to as I said after the new
year
god bless Merry Christmas Godspeed and
the the frog also says Merry Christmas
as well